en este cementerio de cantarranas una
aldea a 40 kilómetros de tegucigalpa
clarisa gaitán le lleva flores a su
padre francisco gaytán el que hasta hace
poco menos de un mes era el alcalde del
pueblo
mi padre actualmente
apostaba por el quinto periodo ya tenía
16 años de estar como alcalde de
cantarranas y la única manera en la que
podrían sacarlo del poder es asesinando
la arrebatándole la vida según el
dictamen forense francisco gaytán
recibió 15 impactos de bala 1 fulminante
mientras presidía una reunión en una de
las aldeas del municipio el mismo que
transformó recientemente para el turismo
dejando como legado una verdadera
galería a cielo abierto también
decidieron hacerle un homenaje a quien
en vida fuera a berta cáceres se llama
me lo dijo el río como pueden ver tiene
el rostro de ella plasmado están sus
ojos
bertha cáceres la icónica líder indígena
y ambientalista también fue asesinada en
honduras destino que temen varios de los
actuales líderes políticos del país uno
de ellos es armando garcía alcalde del
municipio de ojojona quien está
amenazado de muerte pero la intimidación
no loco y ve de seguir en campaña para
su reelección
está amenazado por muchas situaciones
tengo dos periodos tres periodos de ser
alcalde voy por el cuarto de la
población que está conmigo apoyándome
pero
eso me ha traído por secuencias amenazas
a muerte
garcía y otros 11 actores políticos han
sido amenazados de muerte en el marco de
estas elecciones según la oficina de las
naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos en honduras un temor latente por
no engrosar la cifra de 29 muertes
violentas registradas en el último año